the un secretary general meeting with
turkey's president erdogan in ankara
before flying on to moscow mr gutierrez
is trying to build on previous turkish
diplomatic efforts with a new peace
initiative involving direct shuttle
diplomacy first in moscow and then on to
kiev
he thinks that there is an opportunity
now and we'll make the most of
what we can a lot of diplomacy is about
about timing
about finding out when is the right time
uh
to
uh
to speak with a person to travel to a
place
to do certain things and and he is going
in the anticipation that there is a real
opportunity that is now availing itself
and we'll see what we can make of it
the secretary general last week called
for a truce over orthodox easter a call
that fell on deaf ears
i call on russians and ukrainians to
silence the guns
and forge a path to safety for so many
at immediate risk
the secretary general continues to call
for a ceasefire but that's very unlikely
to happen the ukrainian side don't want
the conflict to become frozen with
russian troops stationed inside their
country and after two months of war
moscow's made very limited gains if
there's a truce now it'll be very hard
for president putin to declare a victory
i asked russia's deputy ambassador to
the un whether a ceasefire was a
possibility
we don't think that ceasefire is a good
option right now because the only
uh the only advantage it will give it
will give possibility for ukrainian
forces to regroup and to stage more
provocations like butcher like i call to
you so frankly it's not up to me to
decide but i don't see any reasons in
this right now
the conflict has cost many lives parts
of ukraine have been completely
destroyed leaving ruined buildings and
mangled metal but despite all this the
guns still seem unlikely to be silenced
yet
james bayes al jazeera at the united
nations